um the graphical models framework and
how it's set up and some basic uh
background and theorems about
the um
how
markov equivalence class works how do
they do calculus works those sorts of
things today we want to uh find out a
little bit more about where the graph
comes from in the first place so how can
we discover causal relations directly
from data and i'm delighted to have dan
milinski do this for today um we'll have
the same setup as we had uh uh yesterday
we'll have four lectures over the day
we'll go for an hour now have a coffee
break then a two-hour lunch break um
after the second hour and then two
sessions in the afternoon again um i
think
brief interruptions for clarification
questions are good right so please
please engage there and i will try and
keep track of the questions on zoom for
those of you who are on zoom
in any case please help me welcome dan
malinsky he's professor of biostatistics
at columbia thanks for doing this
hello
uh is this microphone working yes okay
let me know if you can't hear me at any
point if i should just speak louder or
repeat anything
thanks a lot to frederick and the other
organizers for putting this together
it's been really great so far
and for inviting me to
to participate
um so so the lectures today will be a
kind of broad overview of a pretty large
research area causal discovery
which is also sometimes called causal
structure learning because you're
learning the structure of a graph or
causal model selection because you're
selecting a causal model or sometimes
causal search because you're searching
for a causal model these are all
synonyms for the same thing which is
learning a graph from data somehow or
possibly a set of graphs
um and as any kind of like broad
introduction to a big research topic
it's going to be somewhat biased towards
you know my perspective on things and my
interests
and i won't be able to get to obviously
everything
that is cool about calls of discovery
even in four hours
but hopefully we'll give you a kind of
flavor of what's going on in this area
introduce you to the main kind of
concepts that will help you
do research in this area if you so so
choose
um
so yesterday
as frederick said the the lectures
yesterday were
from the perspective of having been
given a graphical model uh how do you do
something with it so the kind of tasks
that you were
learning about yesterday was mostly the
task of uh
of deciding identifiability of causal
quantities or interventional
distributions and there's other tasks
that you might do given a graph and
people will go into that later
but a question uh an obvious question
that arises is where does the graph come
from
and there's many different sources so a
common source of information that might
lead you to posit some graph to
represent your your situation is the
experimental design or problem design
of some study that you are engaging in
for example a randomized controlled
trial or some sort of longitudinal trial
or something like that
but there's plenty of
scientific questions for which a
carefully designed experiment is not
possible or feasible or obvious
there are instances where background
theory whether that's biological theory
or economic theory or some or theory
about
the structure of the brain or genetic
regulatory networks
may help you specify a graph or at least
part of a graph but theory of course may
be wrong and sometimes we want to test
whether our theory actually matches
reality
uh theory may also especially in this
kind of age of high dimensional
uh
data big data theory may be
underspecified it might tell you how
some things are related to each other
but it might not tell you how everything
is related to everything else
and experts who may be drawing on some
combination of theory and other
background knowledge may be a source of
information but of course experts may be
wrong experts may disagree with each
other or the problem may be kind of
intractable in high dimensional settings
for expert opinion so the kind of
remaining option that we focus on today
is how to learn something about the
graph from data
and the question is how so there's
different strategies or kind of
categories of approaches to causal
discovery
uh some of which we'll talk about today
um
constraint based learning score based
learning semi-parametric methods uh
optimization based methods and hybrid
methods this is kind of how i
would
carve up the space of possibilities in
causal discovery although there's
definitely algorithms that don't fit in
nicely into any of these categories
for this first lecture this morning
we're going to talk mostly about the
first two
uh constraint-based learning and
score-based learning and specifically
kind of two classical algorithms that i
would say kind of define the the
paradigms that that those are the the
constraint based and score based
paradigms so score based approaches
sorry con constraint based approaches
typically uh proceed by performing by
testing of conditional independence
constraints so different graphs will
imply potentially different conditional
independence constraints on the observed
data distribution and constraint based
methods are kind of the most direct in
the sense that they just test those
constraints and try and infer backwards
to the graph that might have generated
the data and the classic example is the
pc algorithm which we'll talk about
today pc stands for peter and clark
peter spurdys and clark glimer
who proposed the algorithm or early
version of the algorithm in the
early 90s and has been improved in
various ways since then
in the score based approach
instead of testing constraints it
operates on the basis of
optimization of some sort of measure of
model fit or score that assigns for each
graph some number which is supposed to
be you know better or higher number for
for for graphs that fit the data more
well and a lower number for for graphs
that fit the data less well and the kind
of uh
uh
paradigmatic greedy optimization of the
model fit score uh is this algorithm the
greedy equivalence search ges
um which is another procedure that we'll
talk about
so uh as the kind of background notation
what i'll use in this in this talk
i'm going to use the
calligraphic
g for a graph
there'll be different kinds of graphs
we'll talk about throughout the day
with vertices v and edges e
and there's going to be p vertices
and corresponding to those vertices is
going to be a random vector also of
length p and i'm going to use the letter
x to denote that random vector and uh
it's going to be assumed to be defined
with respect to some background uh
common background probability space and
the enjoy the induced joint distribution
or density of x will be generically
denoted p of x okay
what can i help clarify
yeah well you should know that i guess i
guess look out for when it's p of x that
it's a distribution p of something yes
um and to make things more confusing
it's
i prefer to keep the vertices of a graph
and the
elements of a random vector separate
when i can but it's kind of annoying for
the purposes of a long presentation so i
won't typically carefully distinguish
between the vertices of a graph and the
random variables i'll just kind of say v
equals x when it's convenient
and i'll use
these
these sets which will kind of have their
obvious definitions
related to what you learned yesterday
i'll talk about the parents of x in a
graph g
uh the adjacencies of x which could be
uh they're connected by an edge in
either direction the ancestors of x the
descendants of x and so forth uh with
respect to a graph g
and i'll use the this symbol the
perpendicular symbol with d to denote d
separation in a graph and
uh this one to denote the conditional
independence relationship so
d separation is something about pathways
in a graph which you learned yesterday
and conditional dependence is something
about uh how a joint distribution
factorizes
right um
and another note i'll say is that
throughout i'm going to
make reference to this distribution p of
x that's induced by some causal graph g
and in the lecture yesterday you heard
about causal graphs explicated in terms
of systems of structural equations uh uh
sems or scms
and in a later lecture tomorrow by
thomas richardson you'll hear about
causal graphical models from the
perspective of potential outcomes and i
just want to say that everything that
i'll talk about at least in this morning
is fine regardless of which formalism
you adopt whether you think of the
causal graph in terms of the system of
equations or in terms of a potential
outcomes model
nothing makes a difference for what
we'll talk about here
and in this lecture in the morning i
will assume
this kind of major
simplifying assumption called causal
sufficiency and i'll relax that
assumption in the latter half of this
lecture
in this afternoon but for the purposes
of this morning we're going to assume
that there are no unmeasured uh no
hidden latent
variables that act as common causes of
multiple of the measured variables in
our data set
so meaning that our
variables x that we have access to that
we have data on are sufficient to talk
about the causal relationships among
members of x
um that's a major assumption that is
clearly violated in most application
areas and uh we will relax that
assumption as we go on but it's kind of
easier to get started thinking about uh
graphs over x then graphs over this kind
of larger space of possibly unmeasured
and hidden variables
and we're also going to assume uh all
day that the data generating process
contains no feedback so it's recursive
uh meaning that the graphical
representation has no cycles
so with those two assumptions that kind
what that means is that we're assuming
that the data generating process
corresponds to some directed acyclic
graph a cyclic meaning it has no uh
cycles
uh with vertices corresponding only to
the members of x
uh and in part two we'll relax this
um any questions about that before we go
on
okay
so uh if you consider a given dag g
we learned yesterday that there is this
markov property which is sometimes
called the global markov property
that
is a relation between d separations in
the graph and conditional independencies
in the implied distribution in the
induced distribution so if x i and xj
are d separated given some xs
then they're conditionally independent
in the distribution induced by that
graphical model so here x i and j are
just generic members of x and x s is
some subset of the remaining variables
yes
what's the problem with cycles
the problem with cycles in the graph is
that it just makes things more
complicated so there are methods that do
cultural discovery in settings that have
cycles
but a lot of these properties that like
this one for example um and uh ones that
we will discuss later
kind of break down when you start
allowing for cyclic graphical models at
least when you try and be non-parametric
with them in kind of special cases if
you talk about cyclic models that are
linear then nice properties work out but
in the general case cyclic models
introduce a lot of complications they
make de-separation more kind of
complicated they make markov equivalents
kind of more complicated and so i'm just
not going to get into it
um following up on that let me just
unroll any cycles
uh
right so the question is if you had a
cyclic graph could you couldn't you just
unroll the graph into a kind of acyclic
representation over time where things
are causing each other over time um yes
and no there is a lot of work that
proceeds in that direction but it gets
also a bit more complicated so you have
to make a decision about the sort of
speed at which causality propagates
through that kind of system and how it
relates to the granularity of the data
that you have so if you have some time
series data for example
are the causal relationships going at a
rate such that it doesn't introduce any
contemporaneous or kind of cyclic
relationships at the level of time t
um there's a lot of choices you have to
make about how to do that kind of
thing uh
uh properly and there is work that makes
goes in different directions yes but uh
typically
a lot of the times people do like cyclic
graphs in a setting where they don't
have time series they just have like
equilibrium data they have snapshot data
say of concentrations in a cell or
something like that and they want to
allow for the possibilities there's
feedback that generated that data
okay
so again global market property so this
says that z separation implies
conditional independence and constraint
based learning so this is what we mean
when we say that the graph
places a constraint a conditional
independence constraint on the
on the data or on the distribution from
which the data is is sampled
so the constraint is a conditional
independence constraint it says that if
there's this d separation in the graph
if there's something about pathways in
the graph then x i and xj will be
conditionally independent given the set
xs so constraint based methods
directly exploit those implied
constraints on p of x
to try and infer backwards from the data
to the graphical structure that
generated the data by a sequence of
texts testing those conditional
independence constraints directly
score based methods on the other hand
proceed by assigning to every graph g
some measure of how well the graph fits
the data and that measure is going to be
something which basically says
uh
how how many or how or to what degree
are those conditional independence
constraints
um
found in the data itself
and then by scoring different possible
graphs can try and distinguish between
uh which one fits the data better or
worse
um and so higher scores so we have to
talk a little bit about how to define
such a score but once you define such a
score then higher scores mean a better
fit and a score based approach can be
viewed as an optimization problem of
finding the graph that maximizes the
score
okay
neither of these approaches is
universally better than the other
uh but they each have their own virtues
and drawbacks depending on the setting
and that's why i'm talking about them
both
there are also theoretical connections
between these two approaches
you can kind of translate back and forth
to some extent between them and so they
are actually not quite so distinct as
may seem and we'll get to that a bit
later too
a fundamental assumption that both
typical constraint based methods and
typical score based methods make is the
faithfulness assumption
faithfulness is
really key to causal discovery and
there's kind of strengthenings of the
faithfulness assumptions and weakenings
of the faithfulness assumptions and
various particular proposals but always
like some version of faithfulness is
going to arise
the reason is that the markov property
that we just defined
is unidirectional it says deseparation
implies conditional independence
but what we do when we test conditional
independence from the data is we learn
something about a conditional
independence fact and we want to infer
towards a d separation right so we want
to go from the other direction from
conditional dependence to deseparation
that's not part of the markov property
of graphs that's an additional that
there is that link in that other
direction is it a substantive assumption
or you might say methodological
assumption that we kind of have to make
in order to to make this kind of
procedure work
so
uh to kind of put it in a bit of a
slogan faithfulness assumption or
faithfulness assumptions generally
speaking
are ones that tell you or assume
that all observed conditional
independence constraints
have an origin in the graphical
structure that there's no conditional
independence constraints that sort of
happen accidentally or for reasons
unrelated to the graphical structure
um and this puts missing edges in a
graph and conditional independence
relations uh in a one-to-one
correspondence but i want to emphasize
that this is a substantive assumption on
the distribution p of x and in general
is not true it may be violated and
sometimes you can detect certain
violations so here's an example of a
couple examples of where faithfulness is
violated say i just have these three
variables x1 x2 x3 and this is the dag
the true dag that uh relates them but i
also have this relate this deterministic
relationship where x3 is just 2 times x2
it's a deterministic relationship i can
i know x3 exactly if you tell me x2 i
just multiply it by 2.
so by the markov property x3 is
independent of x1 given x2 because
they're d separated right x1 and x3 are
deseparated given x2 so that's what
follows from the markov property but
there's this additional independence
which follows from the determinism
namely that as long as i know
x3 because x3 and x2 are
deterministically related learning x1 no
longer is informative
so that's an additional independence
constraint
which uh follows from this deterministic
relationship that's not implied by the
graphical structure
so that's that's one kind of thing
that's ruled out by faithfulness
another example is what's often referred
to as exact cancellations
and this is easiest to see in linear
models although it's not only a thing
about linear models but imagine this
graph x1 x2 x3
um this is a complete graph every edge
is connected to every other uh sorry
every vertex is connected to every other
vertex and so there are no d separations
that hold in this graph there's no
conditional dependencies that are
implied among x1 x2 x3
but if i posit
a
a linear structural equation model that
corresponds to this graph
and i choose my coefficients in such a
way
that they cancel out upon substituting
uh the definition of x2 which is here
alpha times x1 will be alpha beta x1
minus alpha beta x1
x1 will drop out of this last equation
right so that will end up implying
regardless of whatever the the epsilons
are as long as they're independent it'll
imply that x3 is independent of x1
the influence between
x1 and x3 that's kind of direct cancels
out the influence that's indirect
through x2
so that's an independence constraint
that follows from this choice of
parameters for the structural equation
model
that is not implied by the graph and so
it's a faithfulness violation
so no independencies follow from the
markov property but x3 and x1 are
independent by exact cancellation
so faithfulness rules out both of those
kinds of things it says that the only
conditional independence constraints
uh that i'll observe in the data are the
ones that are implied by the graph
graphical structure
uh it creates a if and only if
here
uh between the uh d separation
relationships and the conditional
dependence relationships in the
distribution for all sets
uh in the set of vertices
questions yes
to try to be able to capture this linear
structure that you can use
in this example
yeah i mean so the question was is it
possible to rephrase this model somehow
within with an additional variable and
yeah that might be possible but the
point the faithfulness is kind of about
the specific set of variables you've
chosen to represent the problem so if
i've chosen x1 x2 x3 and this
parametrization happens
then that's a faithfulness violation i
can try and expand to a different set of
variables if i have data on additional
things like some x4 um but for a
particular choice of variables that's a
faithfulness violation and i should say
there's a large literature on
faithfulness um
you might say that exact cancellation
like this is uh a priori unlikely to
happen out in nature and there's
arguments to the effect of why it is
unlikely uh or why it actually is to be
expected in certain contexts um there's
a kind of mathematical argument which is
that in
in linear models with uh as long as your
prior distribution over models is
continuous with respect to the big
measure exact cancellations like this
are measure zero so they're kind of like
a priori unlikely in some sense but you
can also imagine that in some settings
the system was designed exactly to act
in a way that cancels that exactly
balances things for example in like
homeostasis
uh in your body or in the thermostat in
this room there's a kind of balancing
act in which things are kind of meant to
cancel out and so
it depends if you like measure theory or
homeostasis i don't know
um okay so
so given the faithfulness assumption we
want to learn something about the
graphical structure from conditional
independences
in the data
and an
important substructure that arises over
and over again in calls of discovery are
these colliders uh which we talked about
yesterday or specifically unshielded
colliders meaning variable
triples of variables in which one
variable in the middle has two parents
and those parents themselves are not
adjacent
and that's a very special substructure
in in dags
the reason being
is that by deseparation you have a
marginal independence so
in this example i'm like trying to start
my car in the morning and there's two
independent things which are sort of
related to whether my car is going to
start for example whether i have uh fuel
in the tank and whether my battery is
charged and sort of like a priori
there's no reason why fuel in the tank
and the charge in my battery should be
related to each other they're just kind
of independent things
um
but
if i know that my car doesn't start
then the status of battery charged and
fuel level become informative about each
other
for example if i know that my car does
not start but then i filled up the tank
yesterday then it must be because my
battery is dead
so conditional on some value for car
start
um my fuel level and battery charge
become associated they become dependent
and thinking about this graphically
that latter half is what follows from
the faithfulness assumption so d
separation just says that there's
a de-separation between battery charge
and fuel level given the empty set but
there's no deconnecting path given the
empty set between them
um but uh if that's the only conditional
independence between those three
variables then specifically this
conditional
dependence must also hold
so
and this is just a general fact about
unshielded colliders is that they have
this kind of marginal independence
structure but conditional dependence
implication
given faithfulness
this is very different from a kind of
similar graph over three variables where
i've just made them all go in one
direction sometimes called a chain
and in this kind of uh in this kind of
dag we have by d separation x1 is not d
separated from x3
because there's a deconnecting path
through x2
and by d separation x1 is d separated
from x3 given x2 if i block x2 i'll sort
of limit the ability of information to
flow from x1 to x3
so these chains
whether it's going in this direction or
going in the other direction they both
imply
a deseparation fact which is that x1 and
x3 are deseparated given x2 which is the
opposite of what was uh found in this
unshielded collider example
uh and forks this kind of setting where
uh one variable is a common cause of two
others has the same set of d separation
relationships as the chain we just saw
that in this graph
x1 and x3 are deconnected but not d
separated conditional on nothing
but they are d separated if i condition
on x two
uh so in that sense this chain over
three variables just implies whoops the
same stuff as this uh as this chain over
three variables sorry chain and fork so
whether it's going from x1 to x2 to x3
or from x2 to x1 and x3 implies the same
conditional independence constraints
so this means that colliders unshielded
colliders
act as a sort of smoking gun to
determine some
uh substructures or orientations in the
graph whereas forks and chains can lead
to some amount of under determination
that with just those three variables i
can't distinguish between the fork and
the chain but i can distinguish between
unshielded collider and fork or chain
so how about you so knowing just this
stuff
how about you select a model if you've
again given a set of variables
and given some data that you believe was
generated from a directed acyclic graph
how might you select a model if
computational limitations weren't an
issue well one thing you might try and
do is just list all the possible dags
over that set of vertices that you have
this of course is impossible if you have
like more than four or five vertices but
for a small number imagine that it's not
too hard and i can list from each i can
take each graph and derive the
conditional independence constraints
implied by that graph using d separation
and faithfulness and just test them do a
statistical test of this independence
hypothesis and then sort of like one by
one say is this graph rejected is this
graph rejected is this graph rejected um
and i'll notice that multiple graphs
will imply the same conditional
independence constraints and some graphs
will imply different conditional
independence constraints
this this so if i if i did it in this
kind of setting with these three
variables i can at least determine
whether i'm in you know this part of the
slide one of these three if they're all
not rejected or this part of the slide
if that one's not rejected
um this is of course impossible so we
want a better thing to do
computationally speaking but it's also
kind of inefficient because
why should i test
these three kind of equivalent graphs
equivalent in the sense of implying the
same conditional independence
constraints
separately if i know that they belong to
the same equivalence class so you
learned about markov equivalence
yesterday and so the a better thing to
do would be to search in the space of
markov equivalent graphs so test every
graph in the equivalence class just once
rather than multiple times
and there's a representation of markov
equivalence classes for dags that ends
up being helpful
which is called a cp dag a completed
partial directed acyclic graph
which will basically group those three
graphs that have imply the same
conditional independence constraints
represent them with one structure which
has undirected edges where the
undirected edges mean that there is some
graph in the equivalence class in which
the edge is directed one way and some
graph in the equivalence class where the
edge is directed the other way
and so for for this equivalence class of
three variables the
representation is this undirected graph
and the equivalence class of these of
this structure is just the singleton
it's itself there's no other graph over
three variables that implies that
unshielded collider set of conditional
independence relationships
and you can generalize this to an
arbitrary number of variables so if i
let g be a dag
then the cp dag which i'll call c
completed partial dag
implied by g is a mixed graph mixed
meaning it has both directed and
undirected edges
that has the same adjacencies as g
and a directed edge between x i and x j
if and only if the x the edge x i to x j
is common to all dags in the markov
equivalence class
and undirected edges elsewhere
so it's a kind of single structure that
includes both directed
and undirected edges to represent a set
of graphs a markov equivalence class
that and they're equivalent again in the
sense that they imply the same
conditional independence constraints on
the data or you could say the same d
separations which is equivalent
yes
yeah i think that we're talking they
were called immorality
when the two colliding variables are not
themselves adjacent
good question but unshielded collider in
raleigh center okay sorry
it's not just about the direction of
good question so the question was in
call of duty we're not just learning the
directions we're also learning the
adjacencies of which which vertices are
connected to which others and we're
going to get to a strategy for that in
exactly in just one second i guess here
i was sort of assuming that if i have
three uh variables and i sort of all
know that they're pairwise
dependent in some sense but really i
want to select like all possible graphs
over three variables which includes the
one the empty graph where none of them
are connected or the graph where they
only have one edge and so forth yeah
so um
so the so to to that point
the kind of more
uh sophisticated search procedure
that both takes into account this markov
equivalence thing
and tries to be as efficient as possible
about uh which tests to perform
will be a procedure that does a sequence
of conditional independence tests
to search for possible d separations
basically
and a naive approach would be to
consider for every pair of variables
that i have
all subsets of the remaining variables
right so if if
x i and xj are deseparated by some
subset of the remaining variables it's
got to be a subset of this and so i
could look at every such subset and do
every such independence test
but that would take too long and require
too many independence tests and
eventually many of those independence
tests will have low statistical power
so instead what we do is we take
advantage of some graphical properties
some of which you learned about
yesterday
in particular that
it follows from the dag markov
properties
that if x i and xj are not adjacent
uh then it must be that they're
d separated
given the parents of x i or the parents
of xj so remember like the parents are
sufficient to block all non-descendants
uh once i condition on the parents
they'll be independent of all
non-descendants so this is just like
this follows from that fact
so that means if we knew the parent sets
we would only need to test this
we don't know the parent sets in advance
that's in part what we're trying to
learn so what the pc algorithm does is
it looks at a kind of super graph of the
truth at every step like a graph that
has more edges than the true graph by
construction
and tests all subsets of the adjacencies
of each x i and xj because the parents
must be a subset of the adjacencies
so so the idea is that pc
starts off with a complete graph where
everything is connected to everything
else and it starts off with only
undirected edges because the first stage
is sort of only interested in
conditional dependencies
so the complete graph is a super graph
of anything right any graph that's the
truth
the complete graph is a larger graph
than that one
and it selects conditional independence
hypotheses to test by looking at every
pair of variables so like x1 and x2 and
x2 and x4 and so forth
and testing subsets of the adjacencies
of those variables
removing an edge when it finds a
conditional independence because that
conditional dependence means that they
must be de-separated and that
de-separated means there must be some
missing edge between them
and in particular the kind of schedule
that pc operates under is that it tries
to start off with
the kind of easiest conditional
independence tests to do namely marginal
independence where you condition on
nothing or the empty set and then start
conditioning on more and more variables
more larger and larger subsets of the
adjacencies at every step
so it's like a quick schematic you might
start with you have these four variables
you do some independence tests that are
marginal meaning conditional on nothing
or condition on the empty sets and you
find
this conditional independence holds that
x2 and x3 are independent conditional on
the empty set so marginally independent
and that leads me to remove the edge
between x3 and x2
i do some more marginal independence
tests and find for example that x2 and
x4 are independent also conditional on
the empty set and that leads me to
remove this edge between x2 and x4
then i to start testing subsets of the
remaining variables just one second that
will get higher and higher in
cardinality so i've tested all the
marginal independencies now i want to
test conditional independencies where i
condition on subsets of size one so
maybe i find that x1 and x3 are
independent conditional on x4 which
leads me to remove this edge between x1
and x3
then finally we're going to use that
collider
smoking gun that we talked about in
order to start orienting some of those
edges so the first step just tests
conditional independence and removes
edges
and the second step says if i find this
particular pattern
in which
remember x uh x2 and x4 were
marginally independent but they're not
conditionally independent when i
condition on x1 that leads me to tell
that leads me to conclude that there's a
collider colliding at x1 so that will
orient these two edges in that direction
and then remaining
undirected edges after i've done as many
conditional independence tests as i can
and i've
oriented as many unshielded colliders as
i can there'll be some remaining
undirected edges and those represent or
reflect the markov equivalents so in
particular uh this set of conditional
dependencies i just found is consistent
with both x3 going towards x4 and x4
going towards x3 they're in the same
markov equivalence class and i haven't
found any conditional independence
constraint to distinguish them
that's the question back
[Music]
100 or 200 variables so i'm just
wondering if they're like
um
yeah so the question was for folks on
zoom that
this approach seems to not scale because
you have to do a lot of conditional
independence test so if you have a ton
of variables is this going to be easy to
scale up i will say that somewhat
surprisingly this is a very
computationally efficient approach
if you
make the assumption that the sort of
maximum
uh density of your graph is not so high
so the way that people usually i have a
results in a couple of slides about the
the computational complexity of this but
the way that people typically proceed is
by saying if i assume that my law
for among all the variables in the graph
the largest number of parents is bounded
by some d
for every variable
then i can give you a number that bounds
the number of conditional independence
tests i have to do
so you don't know in advance of course
how sparse or dense your graph is going
to be but it's sort of not uncommon to
assume some sort of a degree of sparsity
and then you can get some sort of bounds
in the end about the complexity
in the worst case it is of course
um exponential in the number of tests
that you have to do but
that's just the np hardness of this
problem
um and i'll add also that in practice
uh pc and kind of related constraint
based methods are often the ones that
scale up
uh the best in the sense that it's easy
to run pc
on
5000 variables uh like and people do
this in genetic applications for example
whereas a lot of other algorithms that's
pretty hard to do um and uh and we'll
talk about that a bit later too i think
you were next
you mentioned
you know the way so
um
is there any kind of
multi-test adjustment
while you know running all these
independence tests is there a fear of
false kind of positives or false
negatives when you're
testing for independence yes for sure
it's a good question uh so the question
was you're doing multiple tests and i
mentioned something about the power of
the tests but is there some sort of
way in which you can keep track of
multiple testing adjustments or or
something similar so yes and no
um yes in the sense that there are
so every test is we're going to see in a
couple slides and every test will be
done with some significant threshold in
practice right you have some data you
know run a conditional dependence test
and you're going to reject if it fails
to
fall below some threshold
um
so there are procedures which so the
easiest thing to do would be to say set
that threshold very low as a kind of
coarse-grained multiple testing
adjustment so that you do many many
tests but you're doing them each at a
very very low threshold so overall your
probability of a type one error is small
it's kind of hard to do in this context
because you actually don't know ahead of
time how many tests you're going to
perform so instead what people do
you can try and bound the false
discovery rates like the expected number
of false rejections
divided by the number of tests that
you'll do as a kind of bound using a
kind of loose bound on the number of
tests that you'd have to perform for
some kind of like density that you're
willing to posit so there are versions
of this procedure which sort of
adjusts the
set that significance threshold in a way
to control false discovery rates for
example in practice i think it's maybe a
little
more complicated than that but yeah
so the question is can we always assume
faithfulness and what happens if you
can't so the answer is no you can't
always assume faithfulness i mean i
think these examples that i mentioned
earlier about determinism
about exact cancellations they're all
reasons to think that faithfulness is
just not universally true but it doesn't
you don't have to look too hard to find
things in those violations
but faithfulness is a very useful
assumption for for learning
uh causal graphs and so it's pretty
ubiquitous or some version of influence
so i mean there's different attitudes to
take about that one is that it's a kind
of feasible methodological assumption
right so that
assume faithfulness until i have some
reason to believe that it's violated and
setting is kind of one attitude that
people take another attitude people will
take is try and
come up with algorithms that we can
faithfulness in some way or another
um
but there are
uh and into your to your question about
what happens if faithfulness is violated
well it might be that i remove an edge
that shouldn't have been removed
right so faithfulness allows me to when
i observe with conditional dependence
remove an edge and if that traditional
dependence is actually due to
um cancellation exact cancellation then
i've just falsely removed an edge and
that might affect which edges are
removed later on in the procedure as
well so it leads you to basically learn
the wrong graph um but it will be wrong
in the sense of having too few energies
rather than to make
um so there are procedures that try and
we can fit for this in various ways as
we'll maybe get to by the end of this
talk
if you weaken your assumptions you're
going to have less strong theoretical
guarantees about your conclusions though
so in terms of like consistency and so
forth you'll sort of run into
difficulties there
i mean
other than mathematical ones like direct
cancellation i mean
it just seems like what you're saying is
some gratefulness is that like the
metaphysical reason why you're observing
those statistical relations
is because there's a polar relationship
so like aside from the mathematical
things like what does it mean to
not assume faithfulness
so the question is about faithfulness
and what whether it's a purely
mathematical assumption or kind of
metaphysical commitment about the causal
structure of the system that you're
studying
i i don't think i view it as a purely
mathematical assumption because even
though
yeah so so the so ruling out exact
cancellations like this for example is
sort of limiting yourself to like a
certain kind of system of study so for
example
systems that operate under a kind of
principle of homeostasis are all around
us and if if those ones are likely to
violate this kind of
assumption then you're sort of saying
well i'm not going to perform well in
that setting but it might perform well
in a different setting
so it is a kind of substantive
assumption even though i write it down
in terms of like the constraints that it
puts on the
joint distribution it's something that
says that there's some settings in which
this procedure will not work well and
other settings in which the procedure
will work is advertised and so if you
want a procedure that will work well in
those settings in which faithfulness is
likely to be violated we're thought to
be violated you have to do something
else and we can face them
yeah so the question is like when we
can't distinguish directions is it
because we can't distinguish between
forks and chains
um but basically yes i mean the idea is
that
all we all we know here uh
so i learned that x3 and x1 are
conditionally independent given x4 that
could arise because of a chain or
because of a fork
right so that's that's a sense in which
the underdetermination follows from not
being able to distinguish some
structures you have to generalize that a
little bit to like larger graphs so
there's kind of like d separations in
one direction versus d separations in
the other direction that imply the same
conditional independence constraints
in the next couple slides we'll talk
about how you might be able to orient
some of the remaining edges using
basically logic on the graph that you've
already learned so some additional
orientations
the orientations fundamentally all
follow from unshielded colliders but
sometimes additional orientations might
follow based on the acyclicity
constraint for example so the fact that
i know it's acyclic will lead me to
orient an arrow in one way or whatever
um
i'll get to that one second
question
about whether you can say something
about convergence the question what sort
of aerobatic do you get the people
necessary
there is no statistical way to
differentiate
between
the three variables
four
and the three what i have to say
yes or no based on conditional
independence without further assumptions
yes
if you want to make further assumptions
for example parametric assumptions you
can sometimes distinguish between those
things
but based on just the conditional
independence constraints that are
implied
they are observationally equivalent
small questions you mentioned was empty
parts doing in every
what exactly is the problem you're
saying is that be hard what's your input
learning the optimal bayesian network
the optimal directory graph from from
um
p of x and it's usually assumed to be
given in p so give x's of size
so it's a size two to the number of
vertices in the graph
yeah
yeah
yeah first minimum yeah
so there's a there's
i i remember i haven't read this paper
in a long time but it's like it's uh i
think it's meek 1994 or something it's
that bayesian network learning is empty
hard i think it's binary variables
size p
that paper is not binary variable
but it's a
constant number of
values per variable okay so just create
a categorical variable but not
continuously
chm is your fault
all right i think so
[Music]
the question is does the order of tests
you do in pc matter uh
asymptotically no but in practice yes
right so in finite examples because
there's a probability that each test
will go wrong then the order in which i
test things because it affects which
edges are remaining in the graph
is
is impactful on the ultimate outcome and
there are i'm just sort of describing
vanilla pc here but there are
modifications of pc that try and
reduce that order dependence uh pc
stable is one one way of doing
and let me put up so i just gave you a
kind of like
step through like a simple version of pc
but here's what the algorithm looks like
in pseudocode right it's it's relatively
short
all it says is that i i start from the
complete graph over some set of vertices
v
or x here
and then i do this loop where s is going
to be the size of the conditioning set
that i'm going to consider so i'm going
to start with size conditioning sets of
size 0 meaning marginal independence and
then s equals 1 x equals 2 and so forth
and so for a given size i'm going to
look at pairs of vertices that are
adjacent
and look at subsets of of of their
adjacencies
and
test the hypothesis if x1 is independent
of xj given that subset xs
according to some given test and
significance threshold alpha and we're
going to go into what that means in a
second but you give me the test
whatever test you want to use for
testing conditional independence and i
can run this algorithm by plugging it in
if i find that conditional dependence
i'm going to delete the edge and i'm
going to record what set caused me to
delete the edge which is called the
sepset or separating set
and we're going to do this
in this kind of loop increasing the
cardinality of the conditioning set
and then when i finish that i've tested
all the conditional independence
hypotheses i'm going to test then i want
to start orienting things so i'm going
to look at every
i'm going to look at every triple of
variables x i x k x j
that are uh pairwise adjacent
so where i is adjacent to k j is
adjacent to k but i is not adjacent to j
so that so it forms this kind of triple
where the two outside ones are not
adjacent but the two inner ones are
adjacent and i'm going to orient them as
a collider an unshielded collider if and
only if
the one in the middle is not in the
separating set
that's where the unshielded collider
rule and faithfulness come in
uh here
um and so then i'll that way i'll be
orienting a bunch of unchilled colliders
and then finally there'll be some
there'll be remaining undirected edges
and i will uh apply a small set of rules
that might uh that you can show
will orient additional edges
uh in a way that just follows by the
asyclicity assumption and respects
markov equivalents
those rules are are these four
um
the i'll just you can talk about the
first couple whoops
to make it clear
so the first rule
says that if i see an undirected edge
between xj and xk
i can orient it as directed from from j
to k whenever there's an arrow from i to
j such that i and k are non-adjacent so
i'm going to talk about x
j
to
x k
and there's an arrow
i
into x j
such that there's no adjacency between
i and k
and so what's the reason so the rule
tells me that this arrow has to go in
this direction
what's the reason for that
otherwise so the the answer is that
otherwise i get an immorality or an
unshielded collider right if i oriented
this edge in this direction then that
would be a collider at xj and so i
should have oriented it earlier
by the collider rule so it can't be in
this direction it must go in this
direction it follows from the
the unshielded collider constraint
another one rule two is about cycles so
it says
uh
let me do x i to x j
remember there's a path from
x i to
x
right so this rule says that whenever i
see this substructure
i have to orient the edge in this
direction because if i oriented it in
the other it would create a cycle
i'll leave the
in the interest of time and we'll read
the other two to prove to yourself and
they're also just telling you basically
preserve
unshielded colliders and don't orient
any cycles and the kind of surprising
thing about these four rules is that
it's easy to see that they're sound
based on just what the kind of argument
we just said but they're also complete
in the sense that there's no more
orientations you could do
besides these four in order to orient
the the cp dag
the question is it possible for two
rules to conflict each other
uh
in finite samples anything is possible
right because in finite samples you can
have conflicting conditional
independence tests which lead to graphs
that like don't really
um preserve the the markov equivalence
class properties for example so yeah in
finite samples you might have to make an
order about priority of alexa graphic
priority of the rules
but
uh as long as your independence tests
are correct you can never have
multiple of these substructures that
conflict
with correct conditional dependence
information
clarify that so
you know any data that you have will be
consistent with
graph
perhaps with way too many edges
so the the the point is that
um
in finite examples and making a decision
about whether to accept or reject a
conditional independence
right so it might be that there's two
conditional dependence constraints which
are not together consistent with any
graph but i've accepted them both
because there's a probability of error
for each one
so it's not about the conditional
dependence as being true or not it's
about whether i've accepted them
okay so
to summarize the logic of pc
um
the the sort of four main points
is that conditional dependencies
correspond to missing edges this is the
markov property and faithfulness the
collider rule enables orientation of
triples so that's where most of the
arrow arrowhead information comes from
other orientations follow from basically
the acyclicity assumption using those
rules or preserving markov equivalents
and then the remaining unoriented edges
reflect the markov equivalents of models
consistent with the data so there it
ultimately returns to you a
representation of the equivalence class
of dags not necessarily a unique dag
and uh to to go back to the
computational complexity point
uh the kind of classic result is that if
you just assume bounded degree so
basically that the max number of
adjacencies for any vertex in the graph
is d
then pc algorithm has a running time
that's polynomial in the number of
variables
uh it it depends exponentially under the
degree so specifically the number of
tests will be bounded by something that
takes like a sum up to d
um and then the if you do start thinking
about variations on pc you might
get different complexity results
um
and then on the on the consistency side
yeah we're at almost that time so uh i'm
gonna come back to some consistency
stuff at the end of this
uh slideshow but the sort of basic or i
don't know classical results about
consistency for pc is firstly
uh thinking in terms of kind of the
oracle setting where you have true
conditional independence information so
the oracle is this thing which you
consult to tell you whether some
variables are conditionally independent
or not and you can show that if i have
correct conditional dependence
information then
pc is sound and complete it returns the
true
markov equivalence class the true cp dag
implied by the true graph g
and then consistency is about what
happens as n goes to infinity and the
kind of informal version is that if you
assume the distribution is markov and
faithful to some dag g
and c is the cp dag implied by g
then as long as i have a consistent test
an asymptotically consistent test of
conditional independence then there's a
sequence of alpha values which i can let
shrink to zero such that in the limit as
n goes to infinity where n is the sample
size the probability of returning the
correct graph is equal to one there's a
somewhat stronger statement that i'm
going to get to i think in the last
couple slides of the slideshow but i'll
return to that a bit later
um
and uh i'll i'll end here for the break
and we'll come back and talk about this
uh after after coffee but there's a lot
to be said about how to test those
conditional independence constraints so
in particular you're always going in in
practice with data you're going to need
a procedure which i called test
in in my
uh in my pseudocode which tests the null
hypothesis of conditional dependence
um you can devise many such procedures
and they'll all look like basically some
test statistic some function of the data
will be compared to some sort of
significance thresholds and uh if you
reject the null hypothesis that means
you're saying that these things are not
independent uh so you
fail to remove the edge or you leave the
edge in but if you reject the null
hypothesis then you remove some sort of
edge corresponding to this d separation
and i'll after the break we'll talk
about how those tests actually work
oh yeah
can i ask on the on the previous
uh slide
so
usually lots of
limit
uh
statements have like finite sample
bounds hidden
uh underneath
um
is there like a
uh meaningful
uh like fine sampled threshold for for
alpha and
that that we
eat
from the proof yeah so not phrase this
thing this way but in the way that i'll
talk about later in the presentation yes
so this is a kind of very weak notion of
consistency it just says eventually
you'll get to the truth
but for someone stronger thing which
tells you about the rate by which you
approach the truth you need to make
someone's stronger assumptions
which i'll get into
in a you know in a little bit of time so
yeah remind me again to answer your
question i think there's a question
right there too question more high level
questions so if you have an oracle that
gives you conditional independences then
you can learn about how to
say that you can intervene on your graph
then you can learn the actual
uh i think in between
are those the two types of operations
people reasons about
um there is a large space of
research in combining observational data
with interventions made of various sorts
and i think you'll hear a bit about that
on friday
but it's always those kinds of like
for example if i could remove an edge or
add an edge somehow
yeah so the interventional data will
typically tell you something about the
joint distribution after i've like
removed the parents of an edge right
because i forced it to take some
particular value
um so you can have a combination of that
information with conditional
independence uh
that you lean from observation of data
and you might also be thinking of like
background knowledge that you might
impose that uh
forces some edges to be present or
something just to be absent or maybe
some orientations to be known kind of a
priority on the basis of
external information and all of that can
be incorporated into these methods so i
i won't go into here but
um if i have
information that this edge must be
present this edge must be absent or this
edge this variable must proceed this
other variable in the order and it can't
go in the other direction i can
incorporate that information at every
step of pc and in fact that's a great
thing to do because it will do much
better in practice if you have such
information
uh
so we have a 30-minute drink now there
will be coffee outside uh and we
reconvene at 11. there will be a bell
huh